everything was knocked out and there was
stream like a river of blood and I was
like oh my gosh hi I'm Tommy I've been a
drama teacher for 15 years hi my name is
Jonah I've been a drama teacher for four
years hi my name is Mary and I've been
the drama teacher for 13 years now my
name is Eric I've been a drama teacher
for just over nine and a half years and
these are my horror stories I've been
teaching drama for 15 years that started
in the summer of 2004 when I went for
being an archery counselor at my
childhood summer camp in Vermont to
being a drama counselor and I did improv
games and whatnot we had this new
musical that hat was called put me in
coach and is about a baseball team
there's a big ensemble of about 16 boys
all playing these baseball players with
two big numbers with complicated
choreography in pairs and whatnot and
it's opening day of the show all the
parents have just come to town for the
weekend and it's Friday night and I get
down to the main house for dinner and
this counselor comes to me and says hey
Johnny that's not the kids name but
whatever anonymity Johnny says he wants
to go to the girls camp to watch his
sister do the play Johnny's in the
baseball humble so I'm like and you told
him that he can't do this because we've
been rehearsing for weeks and we need
him in the show right he's like yeah but
he says he wants to go see a sister and
it seems like what he plans to do so
talk to him so I talked to Johnny and I
explained the reasons why this doesn't
work he has a partner for the
choreography and we're all we're getting
ready for the show and then about 10
minutes before the show I sort of
realized I haven't seen him in about 20
minutes and then someone walks into the
main house and comes to me and says I
just got a call from the girls camp
apparently there's a boy and a baseball
outfit at the girls camp yeah that would
be Johnny and
okay too late to get him back here hey
Jamie will and Phillip gather okay so
Jamie and Philip you know how you're
normally a pair and we'll you're
normally with Johnny well you're gonna
be a triad for today and do the
choreography we'll adjust it in this way
and just go okay let's go go go go go
that was definitely my most stressful
mom and I'd say attracting fish on
campus so I work at a summer camp where
I'm in charge of all the drama that
happens something that's really special
and unique about the summer camp that I
work at is that it's a Jewish summer
camp so all of the musicals that we do
are in Hebrew this was my first time
working at this job so I was working on
the Little Mermaid two days before our
show my camper who was playing the lead
the counselors came up to me and went
Sally had a family emergency and she's
gonna need a leave camp early what what
do you mean she needs to leave camp like
I was like she's playing Ariel in the
Little Mermaid I don't know if you've
ever seen the Little Mermaid but it kind
of she's kind of a little bit really
important so what I ended up doing is I
pulled one of the girls aside who was
fluent in Hebrew I was like listen I
know this is a lot of me to ask of you
and if you don't think you can do it
that's totally fine but do you think you
can step in she was like yeah I got it
and she did it and she was great and
show went really well
so I think I was like 15 and I started
teaching drama at a local church this is
like my first day on the job never done
this before
we were out it was break and I heard
screaming coming from like the jungle
gym area where they had swings and stuff
I was like where's that screaming coming
from this little girl comes over to me
she's like miss miss miss like um Jeremy
fell off a swing and I was that okay and
this child had knocked out their whole
front teeth like everything was knocked
out and there was stream like a river of
blood and I was like oh my gosh I
stopped like the bleeding with my shirt
so I I like press my shirt on onto their
teeth I had to drag him what still like
keeping my top on his teeth and then
finally got him into like the
headmistress office but I literally had
blood all over all over
my top all over myself and it was so
frightening but you know everyone was
like you did so well but at the time I
was so young I'd never seen that much
blood in my life and he was fine but
that was just very scary I teach a lot
of improv and like drama workshops a lot
of like detention centers camps for
incarcerated kiddos a lot of her great
kiddos and they've just blown up in the
wrong situation and they're there I was
doing this workshop one time and it was
crazy because in this Center we were
literally in a 12 by 12 foot space it
was the only space we could use they
didn't have a theater we couldn't really
do it outside because you can't really
have the kids outside so all we had was
this library that like we fit ten people
just sardines in there and we were just
like be super close and play like improv
games with each other there's a giant
window and then just walls and we're
doing this workshop and outside the
giant window I look over and a kiddo
scales like a 20-foot wall escapes from
the detention center everyone see is it
they start freaking out everyone's like
running away everyone's just causing
chaos and we're stuck in this tiny room
with like ten kids being like let's do
improv that'd be fun but they couldn't
focus because the only thing they could
see in this room was the outside where
you just see like police and probation
officers and helicopters and people
going crazy because someone just escaped
from a prison and it was really tough
trying to get them focus again I don't
know I've never found the kid I hope
they did I hope that person's safe but I
also know that was just like the end of
the workshop vegan drama teacher is wild
it's a lot of thinking on your feet
responding to curveballs and finding way
to finding ways to energize kids into
doing things that are maybe
uncomfortable at first or vulnerable or
scary or intimidating or challenging you
are changing people's lives you have the
ability to inspire every person deserves
to feel that confidence they deserve to
feel that self-esteem they deserve to
feel that they can do something super
worthwhile and amazing give it to the
world and they'll receive love and
acceptance and fun for it I also think
it's the most rewarding job ever because
to see how proud kids get of
what they perform and what they produce
there's no better feeling
[Music]
you